okay here's something cool that's going
on that I want to tell you about a
longtime member of the show contacted me
and said hey David listen I i support
your show I want to continue supporting
your show but I want to do something
good for somebody else and I really care
about high school and college students
and I think it's really important to
engage them in politics so I received an
anonymous donation anonymous to you I
mean obviously I know who it is let me
just be clearly about that an anonymous
donation of a free membership
specifically designated for a high
school or college student this viewer
said it is up to me how I give it away
but it's gotta go to a high school or
college student so here's how we're
going to do it if you are a high school
or college student and you would like a
free one-year David Pakman show
membership send me an email david at
david pakman.com one or two paragraphs
why is the david pakman show important
to you and also take a picture of your
student ID and i know that people could
take a picture of someone else's student
ID whatever it's just something Rachel
so I feel like I've at least done some
due diligence in trying to make sure I'm
really dealing with a high school or
college student sent if they send in a
student ID which has a graduation year
that is uh later than now at least that
makes me feel like I've made an effort
to make sure i am following the wishes
of this donor it is I can't think of
anything else I could reasonably do you
could have them send you a current copy
of their transcript of their classes for
the semester with a corresponding ID but
I still wouldn't know that that's them
right in other words you could get a
transcript and ID from you know whoever
uh David Parkman instead of david pakman
you send that you make an email David
Parkman @ gmail.com you send it in I
assume it's the real David Parkman I
wouldn't really know but really in the
end is this your life scamming the david
pakman show for free membership that
would be very sad wouldn't it I think
we're gonna have to go on the honor
system here I think we are so please put
together just a short letter what why is
the david pakman show important to you
what does it mean to you was it
represent in terms of independent media
i will read through them i will pick out
some interesting stories i will select
someone for a
remember ship we could make this a whole
drawn-out complicated contest in the
interest of not turning this into the
apprentice part 10 or whatever where
there's interdependent and conflicting
contest that will ultimately lead to me
selecting a winner but just send me a
note about what the david packard show
means to you i will look through those
notes and we will award a free
membership uh early next week alright we
will take a break coming up next I will
speak to Professor GAD sad about not
trigger warnings not safe spaces but
micro aggressions stay with us gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30 day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s